SENATE CHAMBERS WE WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN
.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES.
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LET IMPAIR THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED BY THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR PAN.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
DENISE LEVERTOV IN HER POEM
BEGINNING BEGINNERS.
SAYS WE HAVE ONLY BEGUN TO KNOW
THE POWERS THAT IS IN US.
IF WE WOULD JOIN OUR SOLITUDE IN
THE COMMUNION OF STRUGGLE.
SO MUCH IS UNFOLDING THAT MUST
COMPLETES ITS GESTURE.
SO MUCH IS IN BIRDS.
GOD OF INFINITE CREATIVITY.
THE CELEBRATION OF PRIDE MONTH-ACKNOWLEDGESAND APPRECIATES THE
RESILIENCE OF THE MANY LGBTQ
PLUS PERSONS.
WHO HAVE OVERCOME EONS OF STIGMA?
DIMINISHMENT AND
MISUNDERSTANDING.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
CONTRIBUTING TO THE ADVANCEMENT
OF SOCIETY.
AS WE STRUGGLE TO FULFILL OUR
HIGHEST IDEALS OF LOVE
APPRECIATION AND UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE MYSTERY OF OUR HUMANITY.
MAY OUR LIVES BE EXPRESSIONS OF
INCLUSIVITY.
AND RADICAL HOSPITALITY FOR
THOSE STILL MARGINALIZED.
TOGETHER WE HAVE THE POWER. TO
ELIMINATE ALL FORMS OF INJUSTICE
OPPRESSION AND VIOLENCE AGAINST
THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY.
AS WE GROW AND ARE AWARENESS
THAT DIVERSITY IS NOT A PROBLEM
TO BE SOLVED BUT A MYSTERY TO BE
LIVED.
AND MAY WE SAY WITH CYNDI LAUPER.
I SEE YOUR TRUE COLORS SHINING
THROUGH.
DON'T BE AFRAID TO LET THEM SHOW.
YOUR TRUE COLORS ARE BEAUTIFUL.
LIKE A RAINBOW A MAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR
NATION'S FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES
[inaudible]
AND COOL [inaudible] FOR ALL.
MEMBERS AS WE MOVED TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
IT IS BROUGHT THEM BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THE HELP FROM THE
COUNCIL MEMBER JOE MUST STOP.
FROM THE CITY OF ANTHONY THIS IS
WITH US JOE GOES A LITTLE WAYS
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE RULES WILL BE SUSPENDED
TO ALLOW LOBBYIST ON THE FLOOR.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE ARE
GOING TO START WITH S. R.
[inaudible]
FORTY FOUR OKAY.
SENATOR WIENER.
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR WINNER RELATIVE TO
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER
AND QUEER LGBT Q. PRIDE IN THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
STONEWALL REBELLION [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MATTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I TODAY I
RISE AS CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
LGBT Q. CAUCUS. TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY FOR I
RESOLUTION COMMEMORATING JUNE AS
LGBT Q. PRIDE MONTH.
THIS MONTH'S PRIDE CELEBRATION
TAKES PLACE DURING THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE STONEWALL
REBELLION.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE STONE WALL
AND IS A FAMOUS ESTABLISHMENT
NEW YORK CITY -- THAT WAS KNOWN
FOR OPENING ITS DOORS -- TO THE
MOST MARGINALIZED MEMBERS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY DURING THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
WHEN VERY FEW ESTABLISHMENTS --
WOULD EVEN SERVE -- THIS
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS ALSO A TIME WHEN POLICE
RAIDS ON DAY BARDS ON GAY BARS
WE'RE NOT ONLY ROUTINE.
BUT ROTH IT ENCOURAGED BY
SOCIETY WHERE PEOPLE WOULD
LITERALLY BE ROUNDED UP.
AS THEY WERE SIMPLY ENJOYING
THEMSELVES PUT INTO POLICE
VEHICLES AND TAKEN AWAY IN AN
EFFORT TO DESTROY THEIR LIVES
THIS IS NOT THAT LONG AGO THAT
THIS WAS HAPPENING. TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
ON JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE IN THE VERY
EARLY HOURS OF THE MORNING --
THE POLICE RAIDED THE STONE WALL
IN -- BUT UNLIKE AT OTHER TIMES
IN THE PAST OUR COMMUNITY SAID
YOU KNOW WHAT.
NO.
NO MORE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO KEEP
DOING THIS TO US.
AND THE REBELS.
AND THERE WAS A RIOT.
A SINGLE BREAKFAST STARTED OUT
RYAN SINGLE BRICK THAT WAS
THROWN.
THAT TRIGGERED AN UPRISING THAT
STARTED A SOCIETAL REVOLUTION IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
THE STONEWALL REBELLION HELPED
TO CATAPULT THE CONVERSATION
AROUND LGBT Q. RIGHTS.
WERE AT THE TIME FROM.
LOCAL DEMONSTRATIONS TO A
NATIONAL MOVEMENT AN
INTERNATIONAL MOVEMENT.
SUBSEQUENTLY THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
THE FIRST PRIDE MARCHES SPRUNG
UP IN LA NEW YORK.
AND OF COURSE MY OWN CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
HOWEVER WHAT FEWER PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT.
I IS THAT THREE YEARS BEFORE.
STONE WALL AND I'M NOT JUST
SAYING THIS BECAUSE I'M A SAN
FRANCISCAN THIS IS ACCURATE
HISTORY. THREE YEARS BEFORE
STONE WALL IN THE TENDERLOIN
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE WAS ANOTHER.
POLICE RAID THAT LED TO AN
UPRISING THIS WAS A COMPTON'S
CAFETERIA AND THE TENDERLOIN --
A PLACE WHERE -- TRANSGENDER
RESIDENTS PRIMARILY OF THE
TENDERLOIN WILL GATHER MANY --
TRANS PEOPLE AND PARTICULARLY.
TRANS WOMEN OF COLOR WHO WOULD
GATHER.
AND LIKE.
THE PATRONS AT STONE WALL THEY
WERE CONTINUALLY HARASSED AND
ABUSE -- BY THE POLICE AND IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THE POLICE
RAIDED AND LIGHT THERE --
SIBLINGS IN NEW YORK CITY THEY
SAID YOU KNOW WHAT NO MORE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO THIS
ANYMORE.
AND THEY REBELLED -- AND THAT --
UPRISING WAS A PRECURSOR TO
STONE WALL.
I RECOUNT THIS HISTORY OF OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE EVEN TODAY --
OUR COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO
STRUGGLE AND THERE ARE STILL SO
MANY AREAS IN THE WORLD AND EVEN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WERE LGBTQ PEOPLE CANNOT LIVE
THEIR AUTHENTIC LIVES.
WHERE THEY ARE HARASSED ATTACKED
ABUSED [inaudible]
EVEN MURDERED.
I KNOW HERE LATER TODAY JUST
THIS MONTH THE MONTH OF JUNE.
FOR TRANS WOMEN OF COLOR HAVE
BEEN MURDERED [inaudible] FOR
AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO WITH AS MUCH PROGRESS AS
WE'VE MADE IN THE LAST FIFTY OR
FIFTY THREE YEARS.
I COLLEAGUES THIS RESOLUTION
BEFORE US TODAY HI IT SEEMS SO
SIMPLE NOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WOULD OF COURSE
DECLARE PRIDE -- ORDER THE CAR
JUNE TO BE PRIDE MONTH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO WHEN
THIS RESOLUTION -- WAS
CONTROVERSIAL -- WHEN EVERY
MEMBERS WHO WOULD WALK OFF THE
FLOOR WHEN THAT BILL WAS
HAPPENING -- BUT THE GOOD THING
IS WE HAD AN EVOLUTION.
AND THERE ARE YOU KNOW IT'S A
LEARNING PROCESS FOR EVERYONE
AND WE WELCOME EVERYONE -- INTO
THE TENS OF SUPPORT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE MORE AND MORE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE EMBRACING.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF LGBT PEOPLE
AND THAT IS AN IMPORTANT AND
POWERFUL THING BECAUSE CIVIL
RIGHTS ARE NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
THIS IS AN ISSUE. FOR EVERYONE.
THE COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
CENTER ATKINS.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR AND I
THINK THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
MEMBERS AS WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN
AND HAS BEEN SAID -- THIS YEAR
MARKS THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE STONEWALL RIOTS WIDELY
CONSIDERED THE SEMINAL EVENT
OBVIOUSLY NOW ONE OF THE SEMINAL
EVENTS -- WITH DUE RESPECT. TO
THE MOVEMENT LEADING ARE FOR
LGBT Q. RIGHTS AND FIFTY YEARS
LATER HOW FAR WE HAVE COME.
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE WE REFUSE TO
WAIT OUR TURN.
WHEN WE WERE TOLD THAT AMERICA
WAS NOT READY FOR MARRIAGE
EQUALITY?
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE OF PEOPLE
LIKE HARVEY MILK IN ANDREW
SHEPHERD AND COUNTLESS MILLIONS
WHO REFUSED TO STAY HIDDEN IN A
CLOSET.
I WILL BE IN NEW YORK THIS WEEK
CELEBRATING THE STONEWALL
ANNIVERSARY.
THE NATIONAL LGBTQ TASK FORCE IN
THE INTERNATIONAL IMPERIAL
COURTS OF THE USA.
OF THE AMERICAS LED BY A SAN
DIEGANS NICOLE MARIE WERE MERECE
ARE CREATING A WALL OF HONOR
NAMING FIFTY ONLY FIFTY AT THIS
TIME OF OUR FEARS TRAIL BLAZERS.
WHO'VE MADE THESE FIFTY YEARS
POSSIBLE.
THIS WALL OF HONOR IS A WINDOW
INTO THE LIVES OF BRAVERY AND
STRUGGLE.
LOTS OF PAIN AND PROGRESS AND
LOTS OF BEAUTY AND JOY.
IT'S ALSO A REMINDER OF WHAT SO
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN DO WORD
DISCRIMINATION.
ABANDONMENT VIOLENCE.
WHICH ALL TRAGICALLY CONTINUE TO
THIS DAY ALSO REFERENCE BY MY
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
WHEN WE WITNESS THE BUTTE BRUTAL
MURDERS?
OF TRANSGENDER WOMEN OF COLOR.
SO TODAY WE WANT TO CELEBRATE
HOWEVER HOW FAR THAT WE HAVE
CALM BUT ALSO TO REMEMBER THAT
WE CAN NEVER BE COMPLACENT.
NEVER.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
THE RIGHTS OF OUR TRANS GENDER
SIBLINGS ARE GENDER NON
CONFORMING AND ALL OTHERS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- I TO RISE IS -- VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
ON BEHALF OF THE IF YOU AYE
LEDGES THE CAUCUS TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT -- FOR THIS -- VERY
IMPORT RESOLUTION ONE THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE PRO TEM -- FOR BRING
THIS -- FORD.
TODAY IS A DAY TO CELEBRATE THIS
IS A MONTH TO CELEBRATE -- THE
THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IS CERTAINLY WITHIN
THE API COMEY OF MANY -- LGBT Q. --
PEOPLE INCLUDING -- ACTUALLY --
THAT.
YOU SEE STILL CHAIRED A FASTER --
EVAN LOW WHO IS -- IN THIS SAY
SIMPLY -- CAUCUSES MEMBER OF OUR
API CAUCUS WELL BUT MANY OTHERS
AS WELL WHO ARE.
IF CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE WE DO
KNOW THAT -- AS WE CELEBRATE
TODAY THERE ARE STILL --
CULTURAL BARRIERS AND AND EVEN
THOUGH -- LOOKING BACK AT AT OUR
COUNTRIES OF ORIGIN YOU'RE STILL
MORE WORK TO DO BUT I AM PROUD
TO SAY THAT TO SOMEONE WHO I A
SON OF IMMIGRANTS FROM TAIWAN
TAIWAN IS OF THESE VOTED. FOR
MARRIAGE EQUALITY FOR LGBT Q. IN
TAIWAN -- SO THERE'S STILL MUCH
WORK TO DO -- BOTH HERE AND
AROUND THE WORLD BUT CERTAINLY A
BEHALF THE LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
DAYS A MONTH CELEBRATE AND WANT
TO URGE AND I VOTE MY THINK THE
AUTHORS AGAIN FOR BRINGING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
BILL.
MEMBERS I RISE IN CELEBRATION.
OF PRIDE MONTH AND SUPPORT FOR
US SENATE RESOLUTION.
FORTY FOUR I'M PROUD TO BE AN
ALLY.
OURS I WANTED TO SPEAK TODAY IS
THE CHAIR OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
CAUCUS AND CALL ATTENTION. TO
THE EXPERIENCES I HEAR FROM THE
L. B. G. Q. COMMUNITY.
LBJ TO YOU EXPERIENCE A HIGH
RATE OF DEPRESSION.
ANXIETY AND SUICIDE TRANSGENDER
CALIFORNIANS.
EXPERIENCE MUCH HIGHER RATES OF
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND SOON SIDE
THAN THOSE WHO ARE NOT.
R. L. B. G. Q. SIBLINGS
EXPERIENCE DISTRESS MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS NOT BECAUSE THEY
ARE DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE OF HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
TREATED.
A LOT OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH.
ISSUES WITH L. B. G. Q. CLING
RUN AWAY YOU.
IS BECAUSE HOW WE TREAT THEM.
NOT ANYTHING THAT'S WRONG WITH
THEM SO WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE WAY WE
THINK.
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE SUPPORT FOR
PRIDE MONTH.
AND PRIDE IN THE OBG COMMUNITY.
AT AND THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
TO REDUCE ANXIETY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T FEEL SAFE SADNESS.
FROM THEIR REJECTION AND LOSS IN
FEAR FROM NOT KNOWING WHETHER
GOVERNMENT WILL WILL ACTUALLY
EACH.
IN THEIR DISCRIMINATION ENTRY TO
MAKE COOLEY.
THAT'S A FEAR DISCRIMINATION.
IS A CAUSE FOR STRESS AND
DISTRESS AND WE NEED TO DO ALL
IN OUR POWER. TO BE PRO ACTIVELY
WELCOME CELEBRATE AND CARE FOR
L. B. G. TO COMMUNITY.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE IN THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL CENTER
JACKSON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE.
AS THE BUBBLE.
OF REPRESENTING THE JEWISH
CAUCUS HERE A TWO DAY -- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROCLAMATION I
WAS ACTUALLY ALIVE IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE AND REMEMBER -- IN
THIS OPENED MY EYES. TO THIS
WHOLE DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
SOMETHING THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN
THAT FAMILIAR WITH EVEN THOUGH
AS A YOUNG WOMAN IN SPORTS I
NEVER REALIZED THAT SO MANY OF
MY EXTRAORDINARILY TALENTED
ATHLETIC SISTERS WERE IN FACT
LIVING DEEP.
IN THE CLOSET.
LIVING IN FEAR LIVING IN SELFLOATHING -- AS THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY DID NOT ABIDE BY THE
NORMS OF THE TIME.
BUT I AM PROUD TO TELL YOU THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
HAVE FOR DECADES SUPPORTED THE
RIGHTS OF OUR R. L. GDP A BT Q.
SISTERS AND BROTHERS.
CONSISTENTLY FOR MORE THAN THE
FIFTY YEARS THAT WE ARE HONORING
TODAY INDEED IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE WOMEN OF
REFORM JUDAISM PASSED A
RESOLUTION CALLING FOR THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF
HOMOSEXUALITY AND DEPLORED THE
TENDENCY ON THE PART OF
COMMUNITY AUTHORITIES. TO HARASS
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE UNION
OF REFORM JUDAISM IN THE CENTRAL.
CONFERENCE OF AMERICAN RABBIS
PASSED RESOLUTIONS CALLING FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AND SINCE THEN.
JEWISH GROUPS HAVE SUPPORTED A
RANGE OF IMPORTANT ISSUES TO THE
COMMUNITY INCLUSION OF GAYS AND
LESBIANS IN THE RABBINATE.
SUPPORT FOR MARRIAGE EQUALITY
ELIMINATION OF DISCRIMINATION
WITHIN THE ARMED FORCES IN THE
BOY SCOUTS.
SUPPORT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS FROM ALL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST BI SEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS.
AND CALLS FOR LEGISLATION THAT
ALLOW TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS TO
BE SEEN UNDER THE LAW AS THE
GENDER BY WHICH THEY IDENTIFY
AND SO I AM VERY PROUD TO STAND
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS.
AND WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
SOME OF THE POLITICAL LEADERS
WHO -- STOOD UP AND IN IN THE
FACE OF ALL SORTS OF
CONSTERNATION OF VILIFICATION
IDENTIFIED THEMSELVES AS WHO
THEY WERE AND HELP TO FORCE THIS
DISCUSSION FORWARD PEOPLE LIKE
HARVEY MILK.
ARE PEOPLE LIKE SHEILA KEWL.
ARE THESE ARE ALL JEWISH OF
IDENTIFIED AS JEWS IN THE COURSE
OF THEIR LIVES -- MARK LENO
CAROL MEGAN STARTED THE LGBT Q.
CAUCUS ARE PEOPLE I CHRISTINE
KEY HOLE WHO IS THE MENTOR FOR
OUR FIRST.
LGBT FEMALE AND FIRST LBGT COMMA
FEMALE PRO TEM. TWO SEPARATE
DISTINCTIONS BUT ONCE IT WE
WARMLY WELCOME TO THIS BODY.
AS WELL AS NUMEROUS OTHERS
WITHIN THE ARTS COMMUNITY AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD TODAY.
WHO CAN NOW STANDING PROUDLY?
A CALL THEMSELVES WHO THEY ARE
IT'S THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE AS
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS.
REJOICE IN AND EMBRACE OUR LGBT
Q. BROTHERS AND SISTERS BECAUSE
WE ARE ALL AFTER ALL GOD'S
CHILDREN WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S
SENATOR DRAWS SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LET THE YOU KNOW LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE RESOLUTION.
FORTY FOUR IN ADDITION TO
PROCLAIM IN JUNE AS PRIDE MONTH
THIS RESOLUTION URGES ALL
CALIFORNIANS. TO JOIN IN
CELEBRATING THE CULTURE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A LONG AND
RICH HISTORY OF LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND QUEER
ACTIVISM.
EARLY MORMON PIONEERS INCLUDE
HOST SAID WHO WILL STUDY A THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY CANDIDATE FOR
PUBLIC OFFICE AND THE UNITED
STATES.
SYLVIA RIVERA A BI SEXUAL AND
TRANSGENDER RIGHTS ACTIVIST
OFTEN CREDITED WITH STARTING THE
STONEWALL RIOTS.
AND GLORIA ON A FUNDS I'LL DO
WHAT A NOTED SCHOLAR OF CHICANO
HISTORY AND LESBIAN RIGHTS
ADVOCATE.
WELL THERE IS MUCH TO CELEBRATE
MANY ISSUES REMAIN THE DENY
EQUAL TREATMENT TO OUR LATINO
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WITHIN THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. ONE AREA OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN RELATES TO
LGBT Q. MIGRANTS TRAVELING TO
THE UNITED STATES FROM LATIN
AMERICAN COUNTRIES.
MANY ARE DENIED THEIR RIGHT TO
SEEK ASYLUM AND OTHERS ARE
DENIED PROPER TREATMENT AND
ACCESS TO SAFE.
FACILITIES.
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE RECENT DEATH OF JOHN A SHOW
UP MEDINA A TRANS WOMAN FROM EL
SALVADOR.
WHO DIED SHORTLY AFTER BEING
RELEASED FROM ICE CUSTODY IN
TEXAS WHILE IN CUSTODY SHE
SUFFERED SEVERE HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS THAT WENT
UNTREATED?
JOE WAS THE SECOND TRANSPERSONAL
TO DIE WHILE IN ICE CUSTODY
ACCORDING TO AN NBC REPORT.
WELL WE CELEBRATE LGBT Q. PRIDE
MONTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE MUST
ALSO REMEMBER OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
ARE STILL NOT ABLE TO LIVE
FREELY. TO SERVE AS AN EXAMPLE
AND HELP INFLUENCE POLICIES
BEYOND OUR BORDERS WE MUST
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT POLICIES THAT PROMOTE
AND TRULY CELEBRATE OUR
DIVERSITY ARE CHEN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS -- CENTER
SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I STAND IN STRONG.
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND AS OUR COLLEAGUES
WERE SPEAKING IN AS OUR SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO PRESENTED THE
RESOLUTION.
I WAS REFLECTING ON HOW MUCH
MORE.
ACCEPTANCE.
AND TOLERANCE AND OPENNESS OUR
CULTURE AND OUR SOCIETY HAS MADE
IN MY LIFETIME TOWARDS OUR LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
NOT ENOUGH YET WE DON'T HAVE THE
FULL EQUALITY AND CIVIL AND
HUMAN RIGHTS.
THAT.
THE LGBT COMMUNITY DESERVES AS
MUCH AS ALL OF US DESERVE WE
DON'T YET HAVE THAT.
BUT THE THE GROWTH IN THE CHANGE
HAS BEEN VERY REMARKABLE AND
JUST RELATE A FEW OF MY
OBSERVATIONS.
WHEN I WAS IN FIFTH GRADE?
I READ A BOOK CALLED CHAMPIONS
IN SPORT IN SPIRIT AND IT HAD A
CHAPTER ABOUT A WOMAN NAMED
ELEANOR TENANTS.
TEACH TENANTS ELEANOR TEN AND IF
YOU LOOK HER UP WAS ONE OF THE
MOST CELEBRATED IN FAMOUS
CHAMPIONSHIP TENNIS PLAYERS IN
THE U. S..
AND WAS THE COACH.
FOR THE OLYMPIC TENNIS PLAYERS.
LITTLE MORE ALICE MARBLE LITTLE
MO CONNOLLY EVEN BOBBY RIGGS SHE
WAS ALSO THE COACH FOR HOLLYWOOD.
AND SHE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST US
WOMEN PROFESSIONAL TENNIS
PLAYERS.
I READ THE CHAPTER ABOUT HER AND
IT TALKED ABOUT HER GROWING UP
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SHE HAPPENED TO HAVE THE SAME
LAST NAME AS MY FATHER'S BLOOD
NAME.
AND THE DESCRIPTION OF HER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WERE ALL
PEOPLE I REMEMBER MY FATHER
REFERENCING IS IT RELATIVES OF
HIS.
AND SO I WENT TO MY MOTHER I'M
IN FIFTH GRADE.
AND I SAID MOM.
THIS WOMAN MUST BE YOUR RELATIVE
SHE'S GOT HER NAME IS MY DAD'S
NAME AND SHE GREW UP IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND IT REFERENCES ALL
OF THESE OTHER PEOPLE THAT DAD
TALKS ABOUT.
SOME TALK ABOUT HER MY MOTHER
SAID.
I SOME WHAT WHY WHAT SHE'S A
LIFE [inaudible]
AND ARE.
THEN SHE SAID ASK YOUR FATHER.
SO I WAITED I ASKED MY FATHER
WHEN HE CAME HOME HE GOES.
JESUS TAUGHT AS A TWO DOLLAR
BILL.
AND I SAID DAD IN COURSE
INQUISITIVE CHILDREN I WOULDN'T
LET UP I KEPT ASKING AND KEPT
ASKING.
AND THEN FINALLY JUST SAID SHE'S
QUEER.
OF COURSE IT FIFTH GRADE I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANT
[inaudible]
WELL.
MY FATHER AND HIS FAMILY.
WOULD NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH HER.
BECAUSE SHE WAS.
OUT AS ONE CAN BE IN THOSE DAYS.
AND I NEVER MET HER.
I THEN STUMBLED UPON HER
OBITUARY.
IN THE SEVENTIES AND IT
INDICATED THAT SHE DIED WITH NO
LIVING RELATIVES.
I'M ALIVE.
MY FATHER WAS ALIVE.
SO FROM THAT POINT ON I WAS
CLEAR.
THAT THIS IS WRONG.
AND THAT I WAS DENIED EVER
GETTING TO MEET.
MY GREAT AUNT.
WHO HAD SUCH A HUGE INFLUENCE IN
OUR CULTURALLY IN THE SPORTS
WORLD?
SO THEN AS I GREW AND MY OWN
DAUGHTER [inaudible]
IS GAY.
CAME OUT VERY EARLY.
AS A FRESHMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND WE LIVED IN IT WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS A VERY TOLERANT
COMMUNITY -- MANY OF OUR FRIENDS
WERE GAYS AND LESBIANS WHO ALSO
HAD CHILDREN WHICH THAT MY
DAUGHTER GREW UP WITH.
AND YET MY DAUGHTER SUFFERED A
SERIOUS DEPRESSION IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND FRIENDS OF HERS WHO ARE ALSO
GAY WHO WHEN THEY WERE LITTLE
AND GREW UP WITH HER SEEM
PERFECTLY HEALTHY WELL ADJUSTED
KIDS.
THEN BECAME CUTTERS.
AND TOOK OTHER VERY SUS SELF
DESTRUCTIVE ACTIVITY AND I WOULD.
AND THEY WOULDN'T TALK TO THEIR
PARENTS.
AND THEY WOULD BE OVER AND AT
OUR HOUSE AND I WOULD TALK TO
WHAT'S GOING ON IN.
AND THEY WOULD BASICALLY START
TO CAN TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T I CAN'T WALK
AROUND AND HOLD MY HAND OF THE
PERSON THAT THEY HAD TO CRUSH ON
IN ALL WE SEE ALL DAY IN THE
HALLWAYS AT THE DANCES ALL THE
OTHER KIDS.
THERE THEY CAN EXPRESS THEIR
AFFECTION FOR EVERYBODY THEY
HAVE A CRUSH ON AND WE CAN'T AND
WERE AFRAID TO SAY WHO WE AR.
AND I WAS SO BLOWN AWAY THAT
EVEN IN A COMMUNITY LIKE
BERKELEY THESE KIDS BELTS.
INTIMIDATED AND SCARED.
SO THEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WHEN I GOT ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
THE SAME DAY I'M CELEBRATING MY
ELECTION CALIFORNIANS DENY GAY
MARRIAGE AND I REALIZE THAT THEY
JUST DENIED MY DAUGHTER'S
ABILITY.
TO MARY THE PERSON THAT SHE LEFT
AND I BECAME A CRUSADER.
AND WHEN ON THE FLOOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN WE ELECTED THE
FIRST OUT.
GAY SPEAKER THERE WERE SOME
COLLEAGUES WHO LEFT THE ROOM.
NOW MANY OF THOSE THINGS HAVE
CHANGED WE HAVE MANY LESS OF OUR
ADOLESCENTS WHO ARE CUTTING
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY ARE GAY
STILL SON [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
MANY MANY MORE PEOPLE OUT AND WE
HAVE GAY MARRIAGE NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
SO WE HAVE COME A GREAT LONG WAY.
BUT WE HAVE FURTHER TO GO AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE CELEBRATIONS
LIKE TODAY AND WE HAVE
RESOLUTIONS LIKE TODAY AND I
STRONGLY STAND IN SUPPORT.
AND I HOPE THAT EVERY SINGLE.
OPPRESSION THAT STILL EXISTS IN
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT IS LGBT
Q. THAT FEELS IN ANY WAY
INTIMIDATED SCARED TO BE OUT OR
PRESSED.
THAT BY THE TIME MY LIFE IS OVER
THAT IS FULLY ENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER CENTER
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
STAND AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF S. SR FORTY FOUR EACH YEAR WE
SET ASIDE THE MONTH OF JUNE. TO
CELEBRATE THE MANY CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT THE LGBT COMMUNITY AS MAY
TO NOT ONLY THIS STATE THIS
GREAT STATE AND THIS GREAT
NATION AND YES THIS NATION IS
GREAT.
AS WE CELEBRATE.
THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS I WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT A ON SONG AMERICAN
HERO.
THAT IN THE PERSON OF BEINART
RUSTED.
MAY NOT RUSH STERN WAS ON
YIELDING ACTIVISTS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR CIVIL RIGHTS DIGNITY
AND EQUAL EQUALITY FOR ALL.
BUT MR RUSSIAN WAS GAY.
MR RUSTIN PARTICIPATED AND
ENCOURAGE NONVIOLENT RESISTANCE
AND PARTICIPATED AND SOME OF THE
EARLY FREEDOM RIGHTS.
WHEN WE TALK AOUT THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE WERE OFTEN ASSOCIATE THAT
WITH DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING?
BUT IT WAS A PHILIP RANDOLPH AND
BEEN ART RUSTIN WHO ORGANIZED
THAT MARCH.
AND MANY OF THE RIGHTS THAT LGBT
CELEBRATE IN THIS STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY TODAY IS BECAUSE OF HIS
EARLY ON SONG AND COURAGEOUS
EFFORTS.
IN THE SIX FIFTIES AND THE
SIXTIES HE FOUGHT TIRELESSLY
I'VE FOR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES BOTH HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND ABROAD.
HAS OPENLY GAY AFRICAN AMERICAN
IN THE SIXTIES MR RUSSIAN STOOD
AT THE INTERSECTION OF SEVERAL
OF THE FIGHTS FOR EQUAL RIGHTS.
THE WHOLE MISTER WESTON DIED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA RECOGNIZED HIM BY PERVS
ANY HIM THE MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
A TRUE TESTAMENT A MISTER
RESIDENTS CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS
NATION I UP FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT AS I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SR.
FORTY FOUR AND AS I SAT HERE AND
LISTENED TO ALL OF US TALK ABOUT
THE PAST.
LEADERS OF THE PAST DOLE WELL
STONE WALL FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
LISTING TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
EAST BAY -- IT REMINDED ABOUT
HOW PAINFUL AND DIFFICULT
ADOLESCENTS PRETEEN AND TEENAGE
YEARS ARE.
THERE'S NOT ONE PERSON HERE WHO
WOULD REALLY OF THOSE YEARS OUR
SALES THEIR DIFFICULT.
MANY OF US ARE WHO WE ARE
BECAUSE OF OUR ABILITY TO EITHER
SURVIVOR WITHSTAND THAT.
TIME IN OUR OWN LIVES.
BUT I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE I HAD THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY VERY RECENTLY TO
HAVE AUDIENCE WITH A GROUP OF
FIVE YEAR OLDS. FIVE YEAR OLDS.
WHO?
UNSOLICITED.
ELOQUENTLY WERE ABLE TO SHARE
WITH ME THEIR PREFERRED PRONOUNS.
AND I WATCHED A GROUP OF FIVE
YEAR OLDS HONOR EACH OTHER'S
PREFERRED PRONOUNS.
SEAMLESSLY NO STRUGGLE NO SENSE
OF CHALLENGE ABOUT WHETHER THEY
WERE FOLLOWING GRAMMATICAL RULES
[inaudible]
AND IT.
HE INSTILLED IN ME A SENSE OF
FAITH.
THAT SOMETIMES WE OFTEN HAVE TO
BE REMINDED ABOUT THE FUTURE.
AND THAT THE WORK WE DO HERE
TODAY WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE F.
R. FORTY FOUR AND THE KNOWLEDGE
WITH WILL HERE ON THE FLOOR
TODAY -- IS ALL WORK NOT IN VAIN.
BECAUSE WE ARE CREATING A
CLIMATE AND A CULTURE FOR THE
FUTURE AND FOR A GROUP OF FIVE
YEAR OLDS WHO HAVE A SENSE OF
CONFIDENCE AND A SENSE OF SELF.
THAT THEY COULD SHARE WITH AN
ADULT -- THEY'D NEVER MET BEFORE
THEIR PREFERRED PRONOUNS AND
HOLD ME TO IT. FOR THOSE REASONS
AND MORE I PROBABLY SUPPORT SR.
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR WINNER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK THE CENTER FROM
LOS ANGELES -- FOR CLOSING WITH
THOSE UP LIFTING A REMARKS
BECAUSE I WE HAVE HAD SO MANY
CHALLENGES AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE SO MANY CHALLENGES -- BUT
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE -- WINNING --
THIS FIGHT -- AND THAT AS WE GO
GENERATION TO GENERATION IT ONLY.
GETS BETTER AND SO -- I AM
OPTIMISTIC AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
DODD.
I THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE BY JACKSON
[inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS A DOG.
HI SORRY I THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SENATOR WINNER AND CENTER ATKINS
I THINK YOU HAVE SOME GUESTS TO
PRESENT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT -- AND
COLLEAGUES -- THE TODAY BE ALSO
BE -- TO TO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
ARE WE ARE HONORING A NUMBER OF
EXTRAORDINARY -- COMMUNITY
LEADERS -- FROM AROUND THE STATE --
AND AGAIN WITH THAT SENSE OF
OPTIMISM OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY LEADING US INTO THE
FUTURE I'M THEIR HERE WITH US
TODAY -- ARE -- COLLEAGUES
MEMBERS OF OUR CAUCUS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WE'RE GOING TO BE HERE
THEY ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
CURRENTLY DEBATING A RESOLUTION
ON CONVERSION THERAPY -- SO
THEY'RE DOING THEIR WORK OVER
THERE I WILL NOT BE JOINING US
HERE BUT THE PRO TEM CENTER
GALGIANI AND I ARE PROUD TO BE
HERE WITH THESE AMAZING LEADERS
AND WE WILL BRING THEM UP -- ONE
AT A TIME -- FIRST -- SOMEONE
WHO I AM -- HONORING TODAY --
ARIA SO YOU WHO IS A CO FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S COMPTON TRANSGENDER
CULTURAL DISTRICT -- THIS
DISTRICT AS A HOBBY OF SOCIAL
CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR TRANSGENDER
AND GENDER NON CONFORMING --
INDIVIDUALS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
BEYOND A DISTRICT AIMS TO
PREVENT THE DISPLACEMENT OF
TRANSGENDER RESIDENTS -- TO
ADDRESS HOUSING STABILITY AND
EMPLOYMENT DISPARITIES FACING
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE OF COLOR --
AND MANY MANY MORE GREATS --
WORKER MUCH MORE GREAT WORK OUR
IS ALSO THE FOUNDER OF THE QUEEN
CULTURE INITIATIVE AND
EMPOWERMENT PROJECT FOR BLACK
TRANSGENDER WOMEN.
UP PLEASE WELCOME ARIA TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELL CALIFORNIA FIFTH SENATE
.
OUR NEXT HONOREE IS AYE GABRIEL
MALDONADO I WHO IS THE FOUNDER
AND CEO OF TRUE EVOLUTION --
TRAVELERS SAID AS A COMMUNITY
HEALTH AND ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION --
SIR -- SERVING RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY WHEN
ISSUES IMPACTING COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR -- AS AN AFTER THAT YOU
KNOW GAME MAN GABRIEL'S MISSION
IS TO ADVANCE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE.
AND HUMAN DIGNITY OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE -- PLEASE WELCOME GABRIEL
MALDONADO TO THE SENATE.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
WORKING ALL DAY
-- NEXON ARRAY
AND I'M HESITANT TO BRING HIM UP
BECAUSE HE'S TALLER THAN I AM SO
[inaudible]
AN EXONERATE.
IS THAT ONCE IN AWHILE -- JASON
COLLINS WHO HAD A THIRTEEN YEAR
CAREER -- IN THE NBA.
AT STANFORD HE WAS AN ALL
AMERICAN AND RANKS FIRST FOR
FIELD GOAL PERCENTAGE AND THIRD.
IN BLOCKED SHOTS.
I JASON PLAYED CENTER FOR SIX
NBA TEAMS AND EARNED TEN TRIPS
TO THE PLAYOFFS INCLUDING TO AND
THE A FINAL APPEARANCES.
AT THE END OF THE TWENTY TWELVE
TWENTY THIRTEEN NBA SEASON.
THEY SAID PUBLICLY CAME OUT AS A
GAY MAN AND A COVER STORY IN
SPORTS ILLUSTRATED BECOMING THE
FIRST MALE ACTIVE PLAYER IN ANY
OF THE FOUR MAJOR AMERICAN
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS. TO ANNOUNCE
THAT HE IS GAY.
PLEASE WELCOME JASON COLLINS TO
THE SAN.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
OUR NEXT HONOREE IS MANDY LEE --
MANDY STARTED HER CAREER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE HAVING SERVED IN
A NUMBER OF CAPACITIES IN BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE.
A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY I'M AND THIS CONTINUE
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY AND ROLES --
THAT ALLOW HER TO EMPOWER AND
UPLIFT THOSE AROUND HER.
SHE DEDICATED HER SPARE TIME TO
GIVE ME BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
CURRENTLY SHE'S AN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE BOARD MEMBER AND
PREVIOUSLY THE BOARD CO CO CHAIR
FOR QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE WELCOME AND THE LEAD TO
THE SENATE.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
KEVIN TILDEN CURRENTLY SERVES AS
VICE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN WATER WERE HIS
PORTFOLIO INCLUDES COMMUNITY AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSERVATION.
KEVIN IS WORK FOR DECADES BEHIND
THE SCENES TO INCREASE LGBT Q.
REPRESENTATION AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDING ESTABLISHING A LARGE
AND DYNAMIC CADRE OF LGBT Q.
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN SAN DIEGO I
AM A BENEFICIARY OF HIS WORK.
KEVIN IS SERVED ON THE BOARDS OF
THE SAN DIEGO LGBT CENTER.
THE NATIONAL GAY AND LESBIAN
VICTORY FUND AND THE NO ONE
EIGHT EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MY
GOOD FRIEND KEVIN TILDEN TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
COME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO RICHARD POP
AND BECAME A NOTARY PUBLIC TOHELP SAME SEX COUPLES REGISTER
AS DOMESTIC PARTNERS.
BY HELPING OTHERS RICHARD WAS AT
RISK OF SEPARATION FROM HIS
PARTNER ERIC SINCE THEY WERE
LEGAL STRANGERS IN THE EYES OF
FEDERAL LAW.
THEY WERE TRANS NATIONAL
AMERICAN TAIWANESE COUPLE.
BOB IN CAMPAIGN FOR THE
PERMANENT PARTNERS IMMIGRATION
ACT.
IN THE INTERIM HE ALSO WORKED ON
THE NO ON PROPOSITION EIGHT
CAMPAIGN.
DETERMINED TO WORK TO RIGHT THIS
AND OTHER INJUSTICES FOR GAY
PEOPLE RICHARD JOINED EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY AREA
MUNICIPAL ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HE AND
ERIC WERE MARRIED.
PLEASE WELCOME RICHARD POP INTO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
COME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE [inaudible]
WHEN?
AND THE WAY.
THE LATE SALLY MILLER JOINED THE
FACULTY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF THE
PACIFIC IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AS THE FIRST FEMALE TENURED
PROFESSOR.
IN SOCIAL SCIENCES AND ONE OF
THE FIRST LESBIAN PROFESSORS.
SHE PUBLISHED WORKS ON WOMEN'S
HISTORY IMMIGRANTS FEMINISM AND
SOCIALISM.
SHE WAS RECOGNIZED BY FELLOW
HISTORIANS AND WAS FREQUENTLY
INVITED TO UNIVERSITIES ABROAD
SEVERAL TIMES AS A FULBRIGHT
SCHOLAR.
SALLY PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND OF THIS YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY ONE PROFESSOR SALLY
MILLER IS THIS YEAR'S POSTUMUS
HONOREE AND HER DEAR FRIEND.
JILL REINA WILL BE ACCEPTING
THIS AWARD ON HER BEHALF SO
PLEASE COLLEAGUES WELCOME JOE
RAIN AT REPRESENTING PROFESSOR
SALLY MILLER TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE.
WELCOME FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
AND LAST ON OUR LIST BUT NEVER
LEAST TOOTIE THOMAS IS A
PERFORMER ADVICE COLUMNIST
ENTREPRENEUR AND CONSULTANT.
TWENTY YEARS AGO TO RE OPENED
LIPS.
A RESTAURANT SUPPER CLUB IN SAN
DIEGO AT LIPS THOMAS AND HER
COLLEAGUES HAVE SERVED UP
LAUGHTER AND CELEBRATION TO OVER
A THOUSAND PEOPLE EACH WEEK. TWO
DAYS ORIGINAL CHARACTER SISTER
NONE IN YOU AND SISTER NONE OF
THE ABOVE.
HAS MADE LIPS SUNDAY GOSPEL
BRUNCH ONE OF THE TOP BRANCHES
IN SAN DIEGO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING TO THOMAS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
IF WE CAN HAVE ALL OF OUR
HONOREES COME TO THE FRONT OF
THE ROSTRUM TO TAKE A PICTURE
PLEASE COMEFORWARD WITH YOUR
RESOLUTIONS
.
REGULATIONS AGAIN TO ALL OF OUR
HONOREES
.
SENATOR BRADFORD WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
SENATOR BRADFORD AT THE PRO
TEM'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT AND INTRODUCE JOCELYN.
MCCALLA WHO.
AN EXTRAORDINARY TEACHER WHO
HAILS FROM THE THIRTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT MR KAHLO IS A
TEACHER JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY IN
COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
DISTRICT HAS BEEN SELECTED AS A
TWO THOUSAND NINE PROJECT LEAD
THE WAY LAUNCH.
TEACHER OF THE YEAR IN
RECOGNITION EVER EXEMPLARY
SERVICE AS THE EDUCATOR AND HER
COMMITMENT TO STUDENTS.
DESCRIBED AS SOMEONE WHO IS
DEDICATED TO INNOVATION IN.
EQUITY MYSTIKAL CACTUS.
CULTIVATED STUDENT INTEREST IN
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY ALL WHILE
CLOSE IN OPPORTUNITY GAP FOR ALL
THOSE SCREWS YOUNG SCHOLARS.
SHE CREATED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS BY
OFFERING ROBOTICS COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING AND ENGINEERING
PROGRAMS ADDITIONALLY SHE ALSO
PROVIDED STUDENTS WITH
INSTRUCTIONS IN TECHNOLOGY.
HELPING TO TRANSFORM JEFFERSON
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL INTO A
EQUITABLE. TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TEACHING AND LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT MR KAHLO.
IS ENSURING THAT OUR STUDENTS
WILL BE WELL PREPARED FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY JOBS OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY.
ITS HIGHEST PERFORM AND IT'S
ALSO COMPTON'S HIGHEST
PERFORMING SCHOOL IN THEIR
DISTRICT.
MEMBERS ARE TEACHERS OF ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST JOBS WE MUST ALL
AGREE NOT ONLY DO THEY EDUCATE
BUT THE TOUCH AND CHANGE THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS THEY BUILD THE
FOUNDATION FOR THE FUTURE.
I'M SURE THAT WE CAN ALL THINK
OF AT LEAST ONE TEACHER THAT HAS
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES
FOR ME THAT WAS JACK ONE HOSS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW MYSTIKAL WHOSE IS
CHANGING STUDENTS LIVES A FIFTH
GRADE STUDENT AT THOMAS
JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WROTE.
A LETTER EXPLAINING THE IMPACT
THAT EXPOSURE TO THE FIELD OF
STILLNESS HAD ON THEIR LIVES.
AT THE CLOSE OF THE LETTER TO
STUDENTS STATED.
I'M LEARNING THAT I'M ABLE TO BE
AN AGENT THE ENGINEER EVEN
THOUGH I COME FROM THE CITY OF
COMPTON.
I WILL BE A ENGINEER I WILL BE A
LEADER. FOR SHOWING ALL STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN COMPTON THAT
THEY TOO CAN BE ENGINEERS BUT
FOR THE MOST IMPORTANTLY
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE
THEIR HIGHEST GOALS AND
POTENTIALS.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO HONOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO STUDENTS.
HERE TODAY IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE.
THERE WERE THIRTY DAY IN THE
GALLERY IS HER DAUGHTER JOY.
COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL --
SUPERINTENDENT DARREN BRAWLEY IN
JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL SOL A QUEEN NO.
MEMBERS PLEASE STAND GIVE
JOCELYN MCCALLA A WELL WORN A
ROLLOVER DO SITS IN A WELCOME.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME YOUR
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
.
SENATOR DOLLY AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE.
THE COUNTRY DOCTOR OF AMERICA.
WHO HAPPENS TO COME FROM MY
HOMETOWN OF BEAVER AND IS MY
FIRST COUSIN?
DR DOLLY WAS NAME TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN COUNTRY DOCTOR THE YEAR
BY THE STAFF CARE.
RESPONSIBLE FOR PERSONALLY
MAINTAINING HEALTH SERVICES FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS IN A
REGION THAT DRAWS PATIENTS FROM
SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SQUARE MILES.
A SERVICE AREA LARGER THAN THE
STATE OF DELAWARE RHODE ISLAND
CONNECTICUT HAWAII NEW JERSEY.
COMBINED.
THE MEDICAL SUPPORT TO BOTH FALL
RIVER MILLS AND MAYORS MEMORIAL
HOSPITAL.
WHICH REQUIRES A FIFTY MILE
ROUND TRIP ALMOST DAILY SO HE
CAN COVER EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
PROVIDE FOR LONG TERM CARE LONG
TERM CARE PATIENTS.
IN HOSPITALS NURSING HOME HE
DELIVERED OVERA THOUSAND BABIES
INCLUDING MY THREE CHILDREN.
I DON'T KNOW WELL MAY MERITED
RENOWNED FOR HIS LEGENDARY
DIAGNOSTIC SKILLS.
DOCTOR DALY GREW UP ON A POTATO
FARM NEAR THERE THE CALIFORNIA
OREGON BORDER AND SERVED AS
MINUTE AT MEDICAL CORPSMAN
DURING THE VIETNAM CONFLICT
BEFORE EARNING A DOCTORATE.
OF PHILOSOPHY DEGREE IN
RADIATION BIOLOGY.
AND A DOCTOR OF MEDICINE DEGREE
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF ROCHESTER
NEW YORK.
NOW I WANTED TO SHARE A FEW
LITTLE PERSONAL THINGS ABOUT
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE A RULE DR
IN AN AREA.
WHERE THE POPULATION OF BEAVERS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE SO MOST
DOCTORS?
DON'T PUT THEIR NAME IN THE
PHONE BOOK AND THEIR RELATIVES
DO LIKE ME SO IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT WHEN PEOPLE THINK THAT
ARE CALLING DOCTOR DOLLY.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY CALLING ME TO
GET TO TO HIM SO -- IT'S UNIQUE
TO HAVE SOMEBODY -- RECOGNIZE
NATIONWIDE -- I'M ASKING WHAT
WAS THE ONE OF THE MOST -- IT.
DIFFERENT THINGS YOU SEEN IN
YOUR CAREER AND HE HAD SEVERAL
STORIES BUT ONE OF OUR TEACHERS
WAS TRAVELING OVER THE MOUNTAIN
TO COME TO TEACHER SCHOOL SHE
WAS PREGNANT.
AND I GOT THE CAR ACCIDENT AND
BROKE HER NECK.
IS A DOCTOR DALY ACTUALLY WENT
OUT ON THE CALL WITH THE EMTS.
SECURED HER KNACK.
ROAD WITH HER IN THE ANALYSTS TO
READING WHICH WAS A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILES AWAY.
DELIVERED THE BABY AND THEN
STATE FOR SURGERY TO TO PREPARE
KNACK AND SHE SURVIVED AS LONG
AS AS WELL AS OUR DAUGHTER SO
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS YOU
SEE AND READ RULE AMERICA.
AS DOCTOR SO IS WITH THE OF
PRIDE AND JOY -- FOR TO HAVE
DOCTOR DOLLY HERE REPRESENTING.
THE FIRST SENATE DISTRICT CAN SO --
LIKE TO GIVE YOU A WARM WELCOME
FOR DR DALLAS.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME HERE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
.
HI MEMBERS MOVING RIGHT ALONG
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE ME READ
THE MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
MATT PRESIDENT I'M DREDGING FIRM
ON THE BODY THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDED AND ON THIS DAY PASSED
AS AMENDED SENATE BILL
757-879-1041 OH SIX AND SENATE
BILL.
FOUR SIXTY NINE RESPECT FOR THE
PRESSURE ON THE BODY TO
CONCURRENT SENTIMENTS.
IT ASSN WILSON SHE CLICK OF THE
ASSEMBLY.
BILL SUPPORTER TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOVING TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR PURPOSE TO
RISE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE
SENATE RULES FOR BILLS HEARD
REPORTED BY THE BUDGET FIFTH
REVIEW COMMITTEE TODAY AND THE
BILL'S AMENDED ON JUNE TWENTIETH
TWENTY NINETEEN SO THE BILLS ARE
PLACED.
ON THIRD READING AND PROPERLY
BEFORE THIS HOUSE FOR TODAY'S
SESSION.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL CINDER NIELSEN
AND PRESENT I WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL IS
URGING AN AYE VOTE SENATOR
NIELSEN IS URGING A NO VOTE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
I PURCHASED.
NO BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO.
AYE CHANGE [inaudible]
NO.
DALLY.
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON AYE JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
NO.
AYE AYES TWENTY EIGHT NOS.
ELEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME GALGIANI.
HI.
BY THREE NINE THOSE ELEVEN THE
SENATE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO A WILL BE WAIVED
FOR THE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB NINE FORTY FIVE ON WEDNESDAY
WITHOUT TWO DAYS NOTICE TO THE
DAILY FILE.
SENATOR HILL UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT FIND A PLACE FOR
SUPPER PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE TEN EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE EGGMAN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SIR ANYONE ELSE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE THE DESK WILL
NOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
WITH THE MOMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
536-006-3210. NINETY FIVE TWELVE
OH EIGHT ONE SIXTY SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED READ
WE'RE MOVING THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM THIRTY THREE
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE SO CONFIRMATION AT ATTY
THE CROSS TO THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION
SHERIFF WILLIAM GORE AND CHIEF
ANDREW MILLS TO THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
ALL OF THESE APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON THE NINETEENTH OF JUNE ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
I PURCHASED.
I BRADFORD.
AYE COMING AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
I DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
AYE JACKSON.
AYE JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SIZE FORTY NO ZERO THE
GOVERNOR'S OUR APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY SEVEN BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACT GOING TO CANNABIS AND
CLEAN THERE'S THREATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
HAPPY MONDAY COLLEAGUES AB.
NINETY SEVEN MAKES CHANGES TO
THE CANNABIS RELATED LOSS TO
HELP PEOPLE INTO INTO AND RETAIN
IN THE LEGAL MARKET.
THE BILL STRENGTHENS THE STATE'S
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY ON
CANNABIS ACTIVITIES AND ALLOWS
LICENSING ENTITIES THE ISSUE
CITATIONS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FINE. TO HELP LICENSEES AND
OPERATORS REMAINING LEGAL MARKET
THIS TRAILER BILL WILL CONTINUE
TO ALLOW LICENSING AUTHORITIES.
THE ISSUE PROVISIONAL LICENSES
TO ENSURE THAT THE LICENSING
AUTHORITY IS NOT ALIGNED
APPLICANTS TO CIRCUMVENT
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS ARE LOCAL
ORDINANCES HOWEVER THE AUTHORITY
TO ISSUE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
EXPIRES IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS TWO YEAR
SOUNDS THAT ADDRESSES CONCERNS
WE HEARD FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY THE BILL ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THE BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO ADMINISTER
CANNABIS.
EQUITY PROGRAMS ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL ALSO MAY FOR CLARIFYING
CHANGES FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ORGANIC CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS AND
MANUFACTURED CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR ALAN.
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE ADD YOUR WE'RE WORKING
TO ADD TO REDUCE THE HI THE THE
SEA QUEST.
TIMELINE FROM FIVE AM TO TWO
YEARS AND AND I'M I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
BRADFORD.
YES MEN PRESENT I JUST BE BRIEF --
I TO SUPPORT AB NINETY SEVEN AND
I AS OUR BUDGET YOUR STATED
ABOUT THE LICENSING AND AND AND
FUNDS ARE MADE AVAILABLE BUT THE
PART THAT REALLY MOVED ME.
IS THE EQUITY PIECE THAT WE'RE
VERY MUCH CONCERNED WITH SO --
IN THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITTED TO
THAT SO FOR THAT REASON AS WELL
AS ALL THAT'S BEEN STATED I
THRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER WHICH WOULD
JUDGE CLOSE EFFORT I VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO BILL.
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI.
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE OR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JONES.
NO LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY A COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
EYES TWENTY EIGHT NINE AND KNOWS
NINE ON THE URGENCY EYES TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE JUST WAITING ON
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FATHER WILL BE
PASSED OUT TO YOU SHORTLY.
SO JUST HANG TIGHT FOR A MINUTE
.
MEMBERS WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILES SENATOR
WIENER WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO YOUR
JOURNEY MEMORY.
SENATOR WIENER BUT THANK YOU --
MADAM PRESIDENT.
CALLING SIDE RELATIVE -- TO OUR
CELEBRATION EARLIER TODAY ABOUT --
PRIDE MONTH I THINK YOU HEARD.
SOME CONVERSATION ICING AND SOME
REMARKS BY A NUMBER OF US ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF BY TRANS WOMEN OF
COLOR WHO ARE BEING MURDERED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
I RISE TODAY TO US SO WE DURING
A MEMORY OF FOR TRANSGENDER
WOMEN -- WHO -- HAVE PASSED AWAY
OR BEEN MURDERED -- JUST DURING
THE MONTH OF JUNE. FIVE THERE
FOUR OF THEM CHANEL SCURLOCK AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN TRANS WOMAN --
HIS FRIEND DESCRIBED HER AS
SOMEONE WHO QUOTE LIVE LIFE AS
SHE WANTED.
AMAZON UNAPOLOGETICALLY HERSELF
AND QUOTE.
I SHALL LINDSEY AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN TRANS WOMAN WHO WORKED
AT A HOSPICE CARE FACILITY.
AND WAS KNOWN TO BE EXTREMELY
KIND AND CARING.
JOHANNA MEDINA A TRANS WOMAN
FROM EL SALVADOR WHO CAME TO THE
U. S..
SEEKING ASYLUM FROM TRANSPHOBIA.
I SHE PASSED AWAY AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER.
IN THE SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
I WILL BEING HELD IN ICE CUSTODY
FROM COMPLICATIONS SURROUNDING.
THE LACK OF HIV MEDICATION.
AND SO WE SPEARS A TRANS WOMAN.
WHO ALWAYS PRIORITIZED HER
COMMUNITIES AND WAS INVOLVED IN
HER LOCAL LGBT LINE AMERICAN YOU
CENTERS?
COLLEAGUES TRANS WOMEN
ESPECIALLY TRANS WOMEN OF COLOR.
I REMAIN ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN OUR
SOCIETY -- THE OUTRAGEOUS LEVEL
OF VIOLENCE AGAINST THESE WOMEN --
AND THE MURDERS OF THESE WOMEN
THAT'S JUST UNACCEPTABLE AND WE
HAVE TO COMMIT TO REDUCING THE
VIOLENCE I ALSO WE ADJOURN IN
THEIR MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING ALL OF THEIR
NAMES FORWARD SO THEY CANNOT BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
MEMBERS YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
A SUPPLEMENTAL SENATE FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM.
ONE FOURTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FIVE OF THE
CAMINO BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW AND
THAT GOING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
MAKING PURPOSE IN THE FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT ME LEAVE THE RELATE
TO THE BUDGET [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL [inaudible]
YOU. FIVE PLEASE TAKE YOUR TIME.
UBER LARGE FINE.
GO [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
SB SEVENTY FIVE IS THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION ON THE
BEST TRAILER BILL AND CONTAIN
STATUTORY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING A
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES.
FIVE THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION IN ONE TIME PROP
NINETY FUNDING FOR THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT
PROGRAMS.
IT CREATES THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
EARLY INTERVENTION PRESCHOOL
GRANT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND BRINGS LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO THE
STATE WIDE BASE.
BASE RATE FOR SPECIAL ED.
IT ESTABLISHES THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT THE FUND
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
MIDDLE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
ENTITIES IT MAKES A VARIETY OF
OTHER EARLY AND IN CASE YOU
TWELVE STATUTORY CHANGES RELATED.
TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
BACK IN THE ARTS LETTER
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL.
I CHANGE.
BY.
DALY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
BY STONE.
NO -- BURKE.
OUR CASKEY.
AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS%
BATES.
NO [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ RIGHT.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY EIGHT BY THE
COMEDIAN BUT IN FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACTING TO HEALTH AND MAKE IN
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
BACK TO ME LEGAL RELATED BUT
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS THE FIRST OF
TO HELP ON THE BEST BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS.
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING IT
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL INCLUDED IT'S A
THORNY RESPONSIBILITIES AND
MAKES THE SURGEON GENERAL
APPOINTEES SUBJECT TO SENATE
CONFIRMATION.
AFTER JULY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN
IT IMPROVES ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTH COVERAGE BY CREATING A
STATE PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOMES
UNDER 6100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
IT IMPOSES A PENALTY AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT FAILED TO
PURCHASE MINIMUM ESSENTIAL
COVERAGE DURING THE CALENDAR
YEAR THE PENALTY REVENUES WILL
BE USED TO FUND THE STATE
PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO MAKE
HEALTH COVERAGE.
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR CONSUMERS IT
IMPLEMENTS THREE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS TO HELP PREVENT
INFECTION AND TRANSMISSION OF S.
T. EYES HIV AND HEPATITIS C..
ESTABLISHES VALUE BASED PAYMENTS
FOR THE MEDI CAL PROVIDER PRO
FOR MEDICARE PROVIDERS THAT MEET
CERTAIN METRICS FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INTEGRATION CHRONIC
DISEASE MANAGEMENT.
PRENATAL POST PARTUM CARE AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD PREVENTIVE
SERVICES.
IT RESTORES OPTIONAL MEDICAL
BENEFIT BET MEDI CAL BENEFITS
ELIMINATED IN TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND NINE INCLUDING
IDEOLOGIES SPEECH THERAPY
PODIATRY IN COTTON SCREAMS AND
WATCHES.
AND IT ESTABLISHES THE PHARMACY
WORKING GROUP FOR THE PROPOSED
TRANSITION OF THE MEDI CAL
PHARMACY BENEFIT FROM MANAGED
CARE TO FEE FOR SERVICE AND
REQUIRES INCLUSION OF FISCAL
ASSUMPTIONS FOR THE TRANSITION.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I JUST WAS TRYING TO DO A LITTLE
RESEARCH OVER THE WEEKEND ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND
PENALTIES THAT WERE PAID IN
2014405% OF THE PENALTIES.
WERE PAID BY.
INDIVIDUALS THAT FILE THEIR
INCOME TAX RETURNS FOR THE IRS.
IN A MADE LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS YOUR
TAXABLE INCOME.
ANOTHER 37% MADE FIFTY THOUSAND
OR LESS SO 82% IN 201-422-01580
2% OF THOSE ARE PAYING THE-PENALTY WERE.
POOR INDIVIDUALS.
AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF THOSE IF THAT DATA IS
CORRECTED.
FOR IF FOR FINDING SOMETHING ON
THE ON THE BACKS OF THOSE THAT
ARE.
EARNING TAXABLE INCOME.
AT LOW LEVELS INSIDE.
HOPING MAYBE SOMEONE COULD GIVE
ME A CLARIFICATION ON THAT THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER MORLOCK ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SINGING
HEARING NONE CENTER MITCHELL JR
TO CLOSE.
SENATOR PAN PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS --
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS --
TRAILER BILL I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT -- IN THE TRAILER BILL WE
WILL BE PROVIDING SUBSIDIES. TO
LOW INCOME.
FORNEY ENSUE NEED HELP TO
PURCHASE THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT --
FEDERAL MINISTRATIONS CUT BACK
ON FINDING OUT TO HELP SUPPORT
COPAYS.
FOR INDIVIDUAL LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO NEED
ASSISTANCE -- SO WE ARE JUST --
TRYING TO BE SURE THAT -- WE
PROVIDE THE KIND OF ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT TO FAMILIES -- WHO
YEAH I SHOULD HAVE HEALTH CRE
COVERAGE I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT --
CERTAINLY -- NOT BEING COVERED --
IS NOT REALLY A GOOD ALTERNATIVE
ESPECIALLY IF YOU END UP.
WITH AN INJURY OR ILLNESS AND
DEATH FIND YOURSELF GOING
BANKRUPT SO I HEARD SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL IT IS BOTH -- WE NOT
ONLY TO HAVE MANDATE WE ALSO PUT
IT TOGETHER WITH SUBSIDIES TO
HELP SUPPORT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
TO SHARE THE DAY TO GET
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE I ASKED WHEN
I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL'S LIKE CLOTHES THANK
YOU YES AND I WOULD JUST
REITERATE WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO SAID -- FOR THE FIRST
TIME AS A RESULT OF THIS TRADE
THE BILL FAMILIES WITH INCOMES
UNDER 6100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
AND AT LEAST ONE OF THE GROUPS
ARE COLLEAGUES MORRIS COUNTY
REFERENCE I KNOW OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD WITH FALLEN UNDER THAT
CATEGORY -- WILL NOW RECEIVE A
SUBSIDY TO HELP THEM -- WITH
THEIR INSURANCE PREMIUMS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
THOSE REASONS THE MORE I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I HARSH LETTER.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
I PURCHASED.
NO BRADFORD.
I CARRY.
BY CHIANG.
NO DALY.
NO DODD.
I THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI.
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
NO MORALE.
NOTE NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
OUR COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
TITLE.
EYES TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE
ASSEMBLY MINUTES ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUT IN FISCAL
REVIEW AND THAT GOING TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND CLAIM THEIR THREATS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES ARE PRESENT SB
SEVENTY NINE IT'S THE MIDDLE
HEALTH BUDGET BILL.
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING THE
PROVIDES COUNTY FLEXIBILITY TO
SPEND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDS FOR INNOVATIVE PROJECTS
WITHIN THE TERMS OF THE PLAN
APPROVED BY THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION OR
WITHIN THREE YEARS WHICHEVER IS
LATER IS THE LATTER.
IT ALLOWS THE FUNDS TO BE USED
FOR THE COMMISSION'S EARLY CYCLE
SAYS INTERVENTION PROGRAM WHICH
RECEIVED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND A CORRECT THE TECHNICAL AIR
IN THE SENATE THE POINT WITH
ALREADY TO THE COMMISSION TO
ALIGN WITH CURRENT PRACTICE I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL.
I BRIDGES.
I BRADFORD I CAMBIADO
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DALY AYE [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR TOTAL.
I JACKSON AYE JONES.
I LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE [inaudible]
OUR CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
BY [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI.
EYES FORTY NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AYE AYES FORTY KNOWS
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE OF FOR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT GOING TO HEALTH
AND MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR TO
TAKE AFFECTED ME LEAD TO RELATE
TO THE BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANKYOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS THE SECOND OF
OUR HELP OMNIBUS BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL DOES
THE FOLLOWING IT REVISES THE
FOCUS OF THE COUNCIL ON HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS BY RENAME
IT THE HEALTH CAL HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION.
AND REQUIRING EVALUATION OF THE
EXISTING HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND OPTIONS TO TRANSITION
TO A UNIFIED FINANCING SYSTEM
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO A
SINGLE.
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM.
IT EXTENDS MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
FROM SIXTY DAYS TO TWELVE MONTHS
AFTER DELIVERY FOR WOMEN IN
PREGNANCY RELATED MEDI CAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
THE MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION.
IT EXPANDS MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
TO ONE HUNDRED AND 38% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL FOR AGED
AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
BEGINNING JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY IT EXPANDS
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
FOR ADULTS AGE NINETEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS BEGINNING
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
IT JUST THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
DEVELOPMENT METHODOLOGY FOR
PROGRAMS FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE PACE PROGRAM.
AND WITH HOLES NINETEEN NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT FROM FROM THE
COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES PROGRAM
UNTIL THE PROGRAM'S RESERVES
REACH A LEVEL EQUIVALENT TO TWO
YEARS OF EXPENDITURES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR DRAWS SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- THANK
YOU TO THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES AS WELL FOR ALL YOU WORK
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE -- I
STAND.
TO OF SUPPORT THIS BILL HOWEVER
I MUST RAISE ISSUES OF GREAT
CONCERN.
THERE ARE MANY GREAT THINGS THAT
ARE COVERED HERE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
ARE NOT.
IN PARTICULAR THE COVERAGE OF
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS.
THIS BODY SUPPORTED.
THE BILL THAT WOULD INCLUDE.
SENIORS AS FAR AS THE MEDI CAL
EXPANSION.
SOME PEOPLE TRULY AGREE THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
BUT WE HAVE MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE FAIRNESS
AND INCLUSION BY NOT.
HAVING ALL ADULTS LOW INCOME
ESPECIALLY SENIORS INCLUDED.
THERE IT THIS IS A VERY SMALL
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS.
THEY'VE LIVED HERE MANY FOR
DECADES SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND YET THEY CONTINUE TO
BE LOCKED OUT OF HEALTH CARE AT
A TIME WHEN THEY NEED IT THE
MOST.
AS SENIORS.
IT IS A SHAME THAT WE COULDN'T
COVER THIS SMALL POPULATION.
THERE ARE ONLY THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OUT OF THREE MILLION
UNINSURED.
OUR COMMUNITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR UNTIL WE WIN.
COVERAGE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHO WORK AND LIVE IN OUR STATE.
OUR SENIORS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
CANNOT AFFORD.
ANY MORE DELAYS FOR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE.
EVERY DAY WE WAIT MEANS MORE
EXPENSE OF EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS.
AND SHORTER LIVES FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO DESERVE DIGNITY IN THEIR OLD
AGE.
I SEE THE TASK FORCE AS MERELY
PUTTING OFF WHAT WE KNOW IS A
REALITY TODAY.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE INCLUDED
JUST LIKE OTHERS ARE INCLUDED.
A SENIOR AS AND AS LOW INCOME IN
THE STATE.
WE KNOW WHY ALL CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD BE COVERED WE KNOW HOW TO
DO IT.
AND I HOPE AND THAT THIS
COMMISSION.
DOESN'T DO WHAT I SUSPECT WHICH
IS JUST TO PULL IT OFF PUSH IT
OFF TO ANOTHER TIME NOT WHEN
YOU'RE NOT TWO YEARS SEVERAL
YEARS.
THAT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DISHEARTENING FOR OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS --
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL JUDGE CLOSE I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BILL.
I BURGESS.
NOPE BRADFORD HI HI KELLY AT ALL
[inaudible]
I CHIANG.
NO DALY.
NO DOT.
I THE RUSSELL.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE OR TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL HI I'M MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE.
ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO -- BURKE I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GLAZER.
I TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTEEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL ONE OH SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET A FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE THE STATE
BUDGET AND MAKING A PURPOSE
THERE FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES THIS IS BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR.
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING AN
APPROPRIATE AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
THE FUN THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL COMMISSION.
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY
COUNCIL AND A RESEARCH CONTRACT
TO INFORM DEVELOPMENT OF A
MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE.
IT REVERTS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
FOR THE COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
IT APPROPRIATE FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION
TO COVER CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE SUBSIDIES TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH HOUSEHOLD
INCOMES AT OR BELOW. 6100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IT
PROVIDES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TO INCREASE RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT BY.
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SIXTY AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM TO INCREASE UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT BY TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
REQUIRES YOU SEE AND SEE ISSUED
TO REPORT BY MARCH.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AND EACH YEAR
THEREAFTER REGARDING THE USE OF
BASIC NEEDS FUNDING AND
SPECIFIED OUTCOMES THE BILL
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
THAT WILL BENEFIT MANY
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY THE
MIDDLE CLASS. FOR THOSE REASONS
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DOT.
HI THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE OR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO.
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO -- BURKE THE PILOT CASKEY.
BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHANGE. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS NINE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE NINETEEN SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY NUMBER
SENATOR DODD AND AQUINNAH HORSE
RACING INCLUDING THEIR THREATS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY SENATOR
DODD.
BETTER PRESIDENT SB FOUR SIXTY
NINE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IT
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND A HORSE RACING LICENSE
WITH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
HORSES WAR JOCKEYS.
ARE AT RISK AMENDMENTS TAKING
THE ASSEMBLY OR CLARIFY THAT A
QUORUM OF THE BOARD IS REQUIRED
IN ORDER TO SUSPEND THE LICENSE.
REQUIRED THE BOARD TO REVIEW AN
SUSPENSION WITHIN TEN CALENDAR
DAYS AND REQUIRED THE BOARD TO
ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS. TO
ESTABLISH AN APPEALS PROCESS
THERE'S NO REGISTER OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL IS RECEIVED ZERO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED.
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DELHI.
I DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ.
HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY HER TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK HI.
CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS.
MONNING [inaudible]
MONNING I SIZE FORTY KNOWS ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE
ANYTHING ANYONE WOULD LIKE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
OUR OUR HI.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
I BILL.
I BRIDGES I BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG
[inaudible]
IDA DALLY [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL I WAS SO.
I TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
OUR COUNTY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS IF THERE.
COULD YOU PLEASE READ THE BILL
THAT WE JUST VOTED ON THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN FORTY THREE THAT WAS MY
FAULT SORRY.
MEMBERS OF THERE'S NO FURTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS THE DESK
IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
WILL -- COME TOGETHER AGAIN AND
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTH AT NINE AM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT
REST OF THE DAY WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
AND WE STAND ADJOURNED